your point
I'm ever going to make Captain I need a
good Mentor I need my Rabbi sorry dude
but this new guy is going to be another
washed up pencil Pusher he's only
concerned with following every rule in
the patrol guide meet more Z robot
Captain engage is that what you think
hey
new captain alert
you must be the new CEO I'm detective
Jake Peralta great to meet you no don't
let me interrupt you were describing
what kind of person I'm going to be I'd
like you to finish
it's not necessary
or I could recap very quickly sure
um let's see I think I said some joke
about being a washed up pencil Pusher no
do the robot boys
the robot voice you were doing when you
implied on a rule following robot I want
to hear it again
right more
serp
robot
that's a terrible Robot Boys yep good
news is our evaluation will be done by
deputy chief Brandt we have a good
rapport he was once my captain so he's
kind of like our grand captain
that is amazingly funny
Olivia Crawford just tweeted a post of
an officer carrying a woman through
needy flood waters spoiler alert they
are of different races Terry teared up I
love when Calamity brings people
together sir it got another retweet from
the mayor he got a retweet from the
governor well I have already set up my
accounts and not to toot my own bugle
but I think I did an admirable job oh
okay what's your handle I'll be your
first follower it's at
526-1796 d6e6
420-486 F6 c74 it spells Raymond Holt in
hexadecimal code it's clever right
Captain are you sure you wouldn't like
some help with this oh no need now for
my first tweet I think I should give an
update on the water main break that's
actually informative NYC H2O Dash main
sit rep colon at
2040 EDT current PSI 456 Max cap
204000 LPM
suck on that tasty lemon drop Olivia
Crawford oh look at that an alert I'm
probably trending already what my
account has been deactivated Twitter
thinks you're a bot why I'm a human I'm
a human male
I had no idea Captain Holt was
interested in food I have zero interest
in food if it were feasible my diet
would consist entirely of a flavorless
beige smoothies containing all the
nutrients required by the human animal
close your eyes and open your mouth this
isn't Burning Man boil
tell me what I'm eating fine it's a
sharp Vermont cabbage
now describe what you taste
jeez
and
jeez
okay that's good but try being more
descriptive I know you love peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches why
their components have a long shelf life
they're cost effective and they're so
simple a child could make them
okay ah who would be better equipped to
deliver a heartfelt emotional speech
about love I have to imagine it's not me
Terry I'm sorry but you're fired Captain
the speech is yours it needs to be
emotional and poetic
can you do it well my first Captain used
to call me Emily Dickinson great
of course he meant it as an insult about
my sexuality but don't worry I am good
at emotion wedding starting soon how are
things going I was just ordained at
www.internetministrynumeral4cheep.com
but I'm having some trouble with my
speech all I've got so far is a poem Oh
a poem sounds romantic
marriage is a contract between two
adults of different families
it's haiku
and a fact
it works on two levels uh it feels a
little impersonal maybe I should wing it
love
it sustains you
it's like
oatmeal okay okay not bad for winging it
I lied
could be two hours the right day
I've just received the email about
whether I've gotten the job as
commissioner
well from the look of my face I'm sure
you can guess what it says
no we have no idea at all just tell us
you monster is there something wrong
with the captain it seems like he's in a
bad mood I don't know who could tell
you're right Captain tough weekend I
went to Barbados with my husband we wove
hats out of palm fronds and swam with a
stingrays I've never been happier
guys impossible to read don't even try
that is without question the funniest
story I've ever heard
he's in a bad mood is he I can never
read them
you look chipper Captain you have a fun
weekend there was a small fire in my
home I lost many photo albums of
Treasured Memories
I'm devastated hey boy you want to
choose where we order lunch from today
really
you're lifting a lifetime ban I thought
my lunch choices were quote unquote
horrifying adventures and diarrhea today
Charles we take that adventure with you
all right I've been craving Sudanese all
day I'll print out some menus
ouch
you ran over my foot
I am in incredible pain
I told Kevin about how I approved of
your strategy for breaking up with
Marcus and he said that we would quote
sociopaths unquote so you're going to
leave them no I think you may have a
point you might need to do more than
simply text a long drawn out breakup is
just going to end in a big scene and
Mark's crying he has so many emotions
[Music]
just so beautiful how much they love
each other
it's a commercial
for a refrigerator yes it is daunting
but I did some research on amicable
breakups I visited
www.ladiesgoodhealthmag.com backslash
sex hyphen relationships backslash
867-599-904 backslash 9432
ampersand200.html
do you know that side yeah well
apparently it's less painful if you
acknowledge the dumpies
feelings yeah but don't worry we'll
practice okay I'll be Marcus
go Marcus
I think we should break up that makes me
feel sad
I'm sad your sadness is noted I feel
acknowledged thank you for breaking up
with me it will take me eight minutes to
collect my things
I think that went very well
so
you're leaving
that must have been a hard decision
honestly
it wasn't it's funny on my first day
here I asked Jeffers to tell me about
everyone told me you were a great
detective but the one thing you couldn't
figure out was how to grow up
well
I think you finally figured it out
well thank you sir I couldn't have done
it without you over the years you've
sometimes referred to me as something of
a father figure did I I didn't realize
that but I want you to know if I had had
a son
and uh it turned out like you
I would be very proud of them
thank you sir
wow I wasn't expecting to get this
emotional it's not bad for an old robot
huh
more sleep
sir did you just make a joke I believe I
did yes I guess in the end we rubbed off
on each other quite a bit
Tyler the sex movie
did I do that right
it was perfect